[Music]
and [ __ ] - Oh news submitted by Frank
from Dallas a restaurant is now serving
drinking water recycled from its toilets
oh [ __ ] they're illegally oh yeah damn
it not funny
and does the customer do the customers
know this why doctor outrage it's a
secret not leaked why why safe Moniz but
do i sell it buy it
I don't think they're selling it they're
just drinking it yeah yeah kind of the
same thing to me it's like you're giving
it to your customers are paying for the
other thing good mom sighs I mean is it
why would they do
is it the gimmick we have is it we're
saving the earth pretty much that's
stupid no not really okay so this
restaurant is in Belgium and it started
serving free drinking water recycled
from its sinks and toilets and so
they're saying that dude this is like
when I'm in a fancy restaurant
and they're like would you like tab or
do you want the beautiful [ __ ] below
and I'm always like give me the tab
[ __ ] that's the deal but here
they're like it's deal proof you want
the [ __ ] toilet water that we
recycled or do you want the bar Exams
like that's what it must be that's smart
and I would have been like give me the
toilet no [ __ ] do the one guy we're not
surprised like Oh what are you drink the
toilet I'm like yeah give me the toilet
rice but then I'd also asked him to
prove it that's a good one
yeah taste it before you give it to me
they give you a straw and then you go to
the bathroom but it's a paper straw
wait it's a paper straw user the toilet
I hate I hate paper sauce - man yeah
well my favorite things is a Moscow Mule
I cannot enjoy them in California
anymore why because the paper straw
thing can't sit by the does the same
Bart you need a strike an injection of
it from the bottom of the cup that makes
it so good
bring your own straw who does that TIFF
you do that okay mom I'm sorry okay so
anyway this Belgium restaurant they
should stick to [ __ ] waffles man oh
you're one of those uh snacks of the
abwehr it's like it's the waffle thingy
the cookie oh it's great yeah we got a
whole stack of them at home and I dip it
in the telecom nice so good it doesn't
need Nutella it doesn't need already
good yeah no but I just made it better
in hey basic [ __ ] next time you do it I
want you to think about what I said and
I'm never gonna be around I know you I
know you will you'll think about what
you're eating the cookie you'll never
brought even when you're around she
thinks about you
yep I feel like I'm in elementary anyway
thanks guys friend you got your best
shooters this is the opposite so it's
like pass Evernote and it just is [ __ ]
you so this Belgian restaurant is not
connected to the city's sewer system so
they really needed a closed-circuit
solution to solve its sewage problem
disgusting that's how they are now using
this unique water recycling system where
they clean with a plant fertilizer Oh
bro
doesn't sound strong enough and then a
part of it no it's like really it's it's
five filtered five-step purification
system obvious enough so then reverse
osmosis
hold on uh let me get to the end okay
please part of it a part of it is mixed
with collected rainwater and using even
dirty yeah
then use for flushing toilets while the
rest is passed through a series of
purification systems indistinguishable
from tap water they're saying that the
water with the results is too pure to be
drinkable so they have to add minerals
in to make a drink that makes sense
yeah and then which led me down a rabbit
hole last night when I was looking into
this so much why can't we drink pure
water like a hundred percentages h2o and
it turns out distilled water water does
not want to be pure yeah so it will grab
all the minerals out of your body you
ingest it which could lead to death
you can't drink distilled water like in
big amounts yeah yeah and also um like
even the the piping in your house my dad
taught me this oh [ __ ] there's a
specific pipe that your water has to run
through because it doesn't copper or
something like that it has to be
specific because if they don't use that
then you can get some sort of like
cancers well what kind of pipe is it
Jesus tell people Google there's this
one thing what's the type of pipe that
you need or you're gonna die I just you
know what we're overpopulated all right
if you don't [ __ ] figure it out fear
well PVC pipes are those safe no it
needs to be specific lasting just go to
a river oh my god I forgot it it's
literally the house where we used to
live that where my lives and that should
never got fixed oh you better go knock
on the door tonight what hasn't drink
the water from the top okay yeah that's
scary what a feel good end of the story
yeah oh you can become sterile not
cancer sterile that's not bad oh that's
a good thing overpopulation again yeah
yeah you don't die it's just you become
sterile yeah I don't care if people die
as long as it's not me yeah are we
friends enough for where you care if we
die depends if you double cross me where
does that even come from
yeah double crosser like I [ __ ] wheel
you on is me and then if you do it again
then it's gross it's a revenger yeah
it's a revenger it's a revenge game over
so they [ __ ] me over and that's a
double-cross or no it's like we are
doing something together right to like
some crooked
crossing something and then poor nobody
I'm getting new friend oh oh yeah did
you double cross oh I bet it was a I
thought it was just a shady Act period
the shady actors but you're right though
because when they [ __ ] rob a bank and
then they double-cross it that makes all
but that is destroying your word and the
honor that you had the spread and there
should be honor amongst these I think
mmm I believe so amen because you agreed
to rob the bank but you didn't agree to
rob each other that's right yeah you're
the gentleman's agreement gentleman or
gentlelady perhaps thank you your Aviv's
agreement anyway we're talking about
water oh that's right a restaurant I
used to work at a water company meat oh
yeah it was called an ajik I didn't know
that they sold ionized water machines it
was kind of like a pyramid scam because
they sell these water thing is horseshit
yeah what is all that of that what's up
bull it's like Osama Brady [ __ ] the
concept is yeah that guy's [ __ ] out
of his mind and he thinks it's the
alkaline in your water yeah that's a bit
of your body very popular with Hollywood
um yeah one of our biggest sponsors was
Aerosmith mr. Steven Tyler I'm giving
out all kinds of Secrets oh look it's
been years
it's popular right now you find water at
7-eleven you can't it's supposed to be
like the time it tastes good but I don't
know if it really has any benefits it's
like neutral or something like it's it's
it makes your body it's a polar theory
is as opposed your bias both will
receive it better because it matches the
pH of your body yeah but then the
argument is everything that you're about
that you ingest your stomach's just
gonna put the doesn't dissolve it
anyways and it still absorbs it so
that's the other argument where it
doesn't have to be pH so what I was
learning about pure water and what it
does to your cells maybe something there
you need to complete that diet if
you complete that thought she was at the
race she liked to had a great head start
and she saw she was beating everyone it
was like well you weren't bored though
you came up okay would you learn about
the water okay so the pure water it
doesn't want to stay pure right which I
said already and so what I end up doing
is it pulls the minerals out of your
your cells like your actual cells so
then it bends up dehydrating your cells
which is which causes organ failure
which then could lead to death so I'm
thinking like I don't know somewhere in
that same science something about the
ion cuz we do talk about like similar so
like if you know like when you learn
basic chemistry water it has two
hydrogen molecules on oxygen
yeah hydrogen because it has one
electron it's easily ionized it could
become plus one minus one really quickly
so minerals such as potassium magnesium
is easily attached to it so it doesn't
want to stay pure as h2o and so that's
why when they pass it through your
system it's gonna start pulling off out
the electrolytes from your cells
electrolyte yeah and so that's why you
want that the stuff that you do drink it
has a bunch electrolytes in it so it's
not doing that yeah and in the way they
do the machine is they [ __ ] throw
electricity through the water really
that's the concept but I heard that it
goes right back to normal after they
broke break it up it goes right back to
normal
anyway when the water comes out yeah
it's just a yeah but the thing is it
does control the pH though that's
difference so alkaline is is pH ionizing
is different yeah so pH is you know
basic acidic all that [ __ ] so the
Machine did both and it filtered it so I
don't know
I think the being water conscious is
good either way
so you're just drinking more and you're
and it's promoting people to drink more
water so it's like whatever gets people
to do that yeah they're even saying that
this water here from the Belgium Belgium
Belgium Belgium Belgium chocolate
Belgian restaurant but didn't Belgium so
I got confused
well they going out of business
something let me go this place is
serving [ __ ] water I want to eat here
well I don't know it seems like they
really embraced it cuz they're even
offering in different forms so like free
drinking water ice cubes or in coffee
and apparently they're also using it to
brew beer that's what I was trying to
brew beer so they also here tastes like
piss water and smells like piss inside
of club soda depends it's really we do 5
is [ __ ] bomb there's a lot of good
craft beers out there yo why does beer
look like somebody just [ __ ] urinated
all over club soda it looks like it for
sure
sometimes smells like it this is people
drinking [ __ ] water and they're all
smiling oh yeah and [ __ ] water they got
poo poo in there man no they don't have
poop it used to be transformed you know
it's too it's too clean it says it
clearly said it's leave the poo poo
vacuum yeah that booboo back in wait but
don't they already do that in space on
the ISS they do that no I mean like oh
yeah there is here like our tap water
it's all recycled anyway right
oh that means you got poo poo mouth it's
not yeah I don't think they're at that
point yet they do they also eat the
water but they release it back out into
what about the kid wrinkler system they
clean it and then they throw it out what
about the kid that's at the plane round
opens his mouth every time the spring
that comes on is that poop water corners
kids are probably eating don't do that
kids they have its separate so there's
well water which is water that you pull
from the ground and then there's like CD
water which is mean what do you call it
fresh water fresh water so it's like
from dams and from rivers and things
like that we don't have or at least in
LA we don't take the toilet water that
we flush and bring it back into the
system it goes it gets it gets cleaned
up and then they leave it out have all
the bacteria [ __ ] do its job and then
they release it back out so it's cleaned
up and then they throw it back out and
then they save the caca
and then they [ __ ] take it to a place
and you know use it for fertilizer so
hope you guys learn
about water - sure did yeah I did and
please subscribe because for more water
those metal pipes we have a lot more
water facts where that came from will
tell you that
[Music]